Back to the code. That's our post object.
Let's get to the actual main handler. Blog front is the handler for just /blog.
The first thing we do is we look up all of the posts.
This is blog front. This is our handler for the main blog URL.
The first thing it does--actually there's some leftover development code here.
Let's get rid of that.
The first thing this does is looks up all of the posts.
We've been using GQL to do queries against the Google datastore.
I was playing around here, and I used Google's procedural language for writing a query.
This looks at all of the posts ordered by creation time and stores them in the post object.
We could have done GQL just as easily to get our posts. I was playing around with something new.
That's what I did here.
This renders the front HTML template with this query, the result of this query, and the variable posts.
I'll show you all of the templates when we're done.
I can also show you what the GQL for this line would look like.
Let me go ahead and give that a try.
I've changed that line to use GQL--the SQL that we've been playing around with.
That just looks something like this--select * from Post order by created descending.
Actually, I think I said 10 most recent, so it would be limit 10 as the SQL for doing a limit of 10.
Let's go ahead and give this a try in the browser to make sure it behaves the same.
I'll reload this page, and it does. Okay, cool.
We used front.html to render our posts. Let's move onto the next one.
This next handler is the PostPage. This is the page for a particular post.
The way you look up the particular post in the Google datastore,
is you first make a key, and in this case I used the from_path() function.
It says find the post with the ID post_id, which gets passed in from the URL--
I'll show you that in the handler definition--whose parent is blog_key().
Now you don't need to do this parent part.
Because I create the blog with the parent, I have to look it up with the parent as well.
This is how I did it--we called db.get(), which is how you look up a particular item.
We stored that in post. Now we see if there's not a post just return 404.
Basically, if the user typed in garbage in the URL
If there is a post, return permalink.html with post equals post.
There's a lot there. Let's talk about how post ID gets into this function first.
If we go down to the bottom past homework 2.
You can see I have defined a couple of URL handlers.
The main one blog is simple. It goes to BlogFront.
/Blog/newpost goes to the NewPost handler.
We haven't talked that yet, but that's all fairly straightforward.
/Blog/ and then a number, 0-9+, this is a regular expression for how
to describe basically an integer.
This goes to the PostPage handler.
This is how in App Engine you pass a parameter into the PostPage handler.
You may have done this differently, but this is how I've done it.
This basically says anything in parentheses here will be passed as a parameter
into either the get or post function for PostPage.
If we go back up to PostPage, a string representing that number gets passed in.
That's why I call int on it. I turn that into key, and then I do the lookup.
Then we call permalink.html. Let's see how that looks in practice.
Here I've gone on blog/3, which was the ID of the last post we just entered.
This 3 gets sent into our function as post_ID. We convert it into an integer.
We make a key, and then we look up that key.
If I were to type in an ID that doesn't exist here, I get an error page.
Now this is a 404, but Chrome is using this error page, because I didn't send any content.
You can make a special 404 page, but I haven't done that, so this is what we see.
If I were to type other junk that's not an integer, we get this different 404 page.
Now, why did we get two different 404 pages?
Well, because it went through two different 404 handlers.
I'll show you that here in our editor.
If we go down to our URL handler, this regular expression only matches numbers--
0 through 9 and then 1 or more of them. That's what the plus means.
That means that's going to go to PostPage.
Now, when I just typed in the letters, this URL didn't match at all,
and this whole block of code kind of fell through. None of these URLs matched.
The WSGI application, the kind of webapp2 handler--the default handler, printed their 404 page,
which says "404 Not Found."
We'll go up to my 404 handler.
If an integer is passed into the URL, we'll make it this far,
and we won't be able to look up a post.
Instead we'll just return error 404, but with no content. That's why we saw that empty Chrome page.
Normally, we'd probably have a function called send 404 or something
that has a prettier 404 with an image or that sort of thing.
We'll go through all the templates at once.